Quick question. What number defines you? Is
it your age? Those lotto digits you just know
will pay off someday?
Maybe you think there's no number that defines
you. But corporate America disagrees. Industry
defines you with three digits, your credit
score, and it influences everything from how
much you'll pay to borrow money to whether
you can buy a cellphone, land a job, or rent
an apartment.
It's not easy to make sense of your finances.
I'm Shahien Nasiripour and I want to meet
people with an obsession to beat the system
and never leave money on the table.
It's become such a popular measure of character
that there's a dating service that matches
people off of it. Maybe it's not for you.
It's definitely not for me. Around 200 million
Americans have FICO scores, but only about
1.5% of them have that perfect 850 number.
One of the folks who knows how to join the
850 club is Stan Kellman. He learned to game
a system after his score fell below 600 during
the Great Recession. Let's give him a ring
and find out how he did it.
Hey, Stan, thanks so much for taking the time
to chat.
Thank you for having me.
What moved you to want to achieve an 850 credit
score?
I just happened to have the misfortune of
graduating with my MBA in the recession and
got into some debt. In the process of settling
that debt, my credit score dropped. What it's
like to live with a low score, it really sucks.
If you have a mark on your credit report,
it will not go away for seven years, for 10
if you have a bankruptcy.
You mentioned that you had negotiated with
your creditors. How did you go about doing
that?
You'll get daily collection calls and they'll
want you to make a payment. What you don't
realize is once you make a payment, your clock
gets reset. By law, after 180 days of nonpayment
is when they are required to write it off
for accounting purposes, and right before
the 180 day mark is when you can call them
and make a deal.
I could settle some cards for as low as 20
cents on the dollar. You are not paying back
what you promised to pay back, but at the
same time, there are big banks that got billions
of dollars from the government in bailout
funds and I didn't. So that was my own
personal bailout.
Why didn't you just stop when you got to 780?
Why did you try to get that elusive 850?
Because that's my personality. I wanted my
perfect score. The scores are not developed
for you. They're developed for the banks to
evaluate your credit worthness. They're not
a measure of your personal financial health.
You can be deep in debt and have a perfect
score, and that's not good for you. And it's
better to have a middling score, but have no
debt.
Let's look at how these credit scores are
weighted. Peoples with perfect 850 scores
never make late payments. The 850ers use maybe
5% of the big credit limit and have had a
diverse mix of loans and card accounts over
the years. They also haven't applied for any
new credit recently.
It's not the fairest system, but you really
don't need to be perfect to get it to work
for you. Wisebread.com founder, Janet Alvarez,
raised her score 300 points, and she's got
tips on how to raise your score and keep it
there.
In order to get the perfect 850 or 860 credit
score, it's going to take sort of impeccable
performance on every aspect of your credit.
But you don't really need it. You don't need
a perfect score to get the best rates or the
best offers. You just need a really good score.
Younger people are inadvertently penalized
because if you're younger, you're just not
going to have a lot of credit history and
to get the maximum boost out of this component
of your credit score, you're going to want
a credit history of 30 years or longer. Even
if your credit isn't great, if you do qualify
for more credit, ask for higher credit limits
on your existing cards or try to get new cards.
Again, that improves your credit utilization
ratio so that opens your score. It can boost
it by something like 50 to 100 points within
a month, depending on how much additional
credit you take on.
There's a different score generated for the
type of loan or the type of credit you're
seeking, so for the purposes of credit cards
or a car loan or a home loan, you might get
different scores, and that's just because
they're looking at different selection criteria
based on what you're borrowing for.
So get to work on your score. Give yourself
some credit along the way.